from the heroes origins two centuries of
injustice the Dark Knight trilogy
possesses a gritty yet fascinating world
here we'll explore the history of Bruce
Wayne and his more realistic rogues
gallery and how three films made us
believe a man could you know not fly but
do wingsuit stuff in a chaotic world it
can be comforting to imagine that
there's a singular force behind
history's most horrifying events
organizations so powerful and secretive
that they can hide in plain sight while
pulling the metaphorical strings of a
society in the Dark Knight trilogy those
theories would be entirely well-founded
since an enigmatic group known as the
League of Shadows has been molding
civilization for more than a thousand
years their theory is that when a great
nation becomes too large and decadent it
needs to be purged like an overgrown
forest secrecy is their calling card but
were given a few glimpses of the
league's actions over the centuries
through their leader Ra's al Ghul we Zak
true loaded trade troops with plague
rats but London to the ground his former
claim likely refers to the attack on the
Roman former capital in 410 AD by the
Visigoths an event that led in part to
the fall of the Roman Empire but Ra's al
Ghul further implies that the league
retained power through the 14th and 17th
centuries around the early to mid 80s
a young Ra's al Ghul then a mercenary
for hire falls in love with the daughter
of a powerful warlord the warlord orders
that Roz is to be thrown into an
infamous prison known only as the pit a
deep hole in an unnamed but ancient
country the Warlord's daughter arranges
to take the place of Roz in exchange for
his freedom
never letting Roz or her father know a
few months later also without Roz's
knowledge she gives birth to his child a
girl named Talia the girl's mother is
attacked and killed by fellow inmates a
short time later and Talia falls under
the protection of bein a man who spent
his entire life in the pit as a young
girl Talia attains a legendary status
among the pits prisoners when she
becomes the first inmate to successfully
escape while she climbs to freedom Bane
holds back the other enraged prisoners
and is gruesomely disfigured in the
process Talia tracks down her father now
a high-level figure in the League of
Shadows and he goes to the pit executing
the people responsible for his lover's
death and
tracting bane recruiting him for the
league and treating his injuries with
the use of a mask that continually doses
him with paint suppressants far away
from the pit on the other side of the
world the League of Shadows plot to
cause an economic collapse in Gotham is
thrown off by an unforeseen factor the
rise of philanthropist power couple
Thomas and Martha Wayne
Thomas a celebrated surgeon is also the
chairman of Wayne Enterprises a
technology and real estate development
company as well as the head of the
charitable wing foundation I lead the
running of our company of a much better
men better Wow more interested men
Thomas and Martha invest heavily in
improving Gotham funding the
construction of an elevated train system
suspiciously similar to Chicago's L
ironically Thomas and Martha succeed in
pulling Gotham out of its depression but
only in their deaths the two are shot
and killed in a mugging by a low-level
criminal Joe Chill the city's elite are
inspired into action helping to clean up
Gotham and create a better if imperfect
place to live little knowing that this
will inspire further more insidious
actions by the league Joe Chill is
hastily arrested for the deaths of
Thomas and Martha Wayne and he spends
roughly a decade behind bars while there
he shares a cell with mob boss carmine
Falcone and manages to glean information
on his criminal activities and that's
when shield decides to become a stool
pigeon exchanging testimony about the
gangster for parole Bruce Wayne attends
chills hearing with a small revolver in
his pocket intending to kill the man who
killed his family
unbeknownst to Wayne Falcone has bribed
the judge moving chills hearing into a
public space so that one of Falcone E's
assassins can get to chill before Bruce
is able to after a meeting with Falcone
and a slap heavy chewing out from Rachel
Bruce realizes that he's ill-equipped to
stop crime in any meaningful way or
protect the people he loves
now you think because your mommy and
your daddy got shot you know about the
ugly side of life but you don't burning
his identification Bruce goes off the
grid traveling the world in search of
meaning understanding and mentorship he
gets that in Bhutan where he's offered
membership in the League of Shadows told
that the league is a force for order the
world's greatest detective doesn't
realize that a group of explosive
enthusiast ninjas might be in the
business of killing people
until his
initiation ceremony during which he's
told to take the life of a man who's
killed his neighbors expressing a
philosophy of non-lethal violence Bruce
blows up the league's compound with
everyone still inside only managing to
save his mentor who he leaves in the
care of a local villager Bruce returns
to Gotham where he befriends
experimental weapons designer Lucius Fox
an employee of Wayne Enterprises who
outfits him with equipment to combat the
city's criminal element was Tom woo oh
you wouldn't be interested man creating
the Batman persona and initiating an
uneasy partnership with detective James
Gordon Bruce stops afresh League of
Shadows plot to release a hallucinogenic
neurotoxin developed by local
psychiatrist Jonathan crane somewhere
around this point versus Wayne visits an
orphanage funded by the Wayne foundation
where a young kid named Robin John Blake
is living an angry child Blake
recognizes something in Wayne anger
masked behind a smile a lot of people
know what it feels like do they be angry
in your bones
Blake feels a kinship with Wayne looking
up to him as a hero figure he deduces
that Wayne is probably Batman and out of
either a sense of respect or an
understanding of what bat snitches get
doesn't tell anyone Blake will grow up
and move out of the boy's home
eventually becoming one of the rare
incorruptible cops on gotham city's
payroll there he'll partner with James
Gordon and become entangled in Batman's
world of gritty animal-based vigilantism
at the end of Batman Begins Gordon
informs Batman that his wearing a mask
and generally making a scene has led to
escalation from the city's criminal
element with one particularly troubling
new figure committing a series of crimes
and leaving behind a Joker playing card
each time nine months later the man
calling himself the Joker is still at
large plus at a lower rung on the
calamity ladder Jonathan crane has fully
adopted his scarecrow persona and is
somehow making a living selling
recreational fear gas presumably thanks
to the fact that teenagers will try
anything these days with public safety
at the forefront of the political
landscape a new District Attorney is
elected Harvey Dent
a handsome optimist who gives a recently
promoted lieutenant Gordon the leeway he
needs to continue collaborating
Batman Bruce keeps a watchful eye on the
new da in part because of the lawyers
romantic involvement with Rachel as the
Joker's crime spree picks up momentum
Bruce decides to focus his efforts on
stopping the city's organized crime
rings ironically not seeing the threat
inherent in a single exceptional
dramatic symbol his war on the mob opens
up Gotham's underworld leaving it
vulnerable to the forces of chaos do I
really look like a guy with a plan with
Batman's attention divided Joker takes
control of Gotham's organized crime
kills a judge and the police
commissioner and reframes the public's
perception of Batman during his reign of
terror
Joker kidnaps Rachel and Harvey killing
the former and mutilating the ladder
burning off half his face and driving
him into the depths of vengeful
homicidal madness as a result of these
actions Batman pulls his emergency cord
a high-tech surveillance system that
creates a three-dimensional sonar map in
real time by employing the use of every
cell phone in the city in the end the
Joker is captured but Harvey's revenge
ride concludes when he kidnaps Gordon's
family and holds them at gunpoint Batman
tackles dent off of a Ledge killing him
and agrees to take the blame for the
disgraced DA's string of crimes he rides
into the night a wanted fugitive and
Harvey's death becomes the precipitating
event in the enactment of a series of
laws that enable the police to go even
tougher on crime suspending their civil
liberties in the name of law and order
during Batman's self-imposed exile Bruce
Wayne works to better Gotham City in
ways that rely more on working towards
meeting the needs of its citizens by
creating a sustainable future and less
on punching guys who steal stereos he
helps to fund an exciting clean energy
project but his sense of moral
obligation forces him to shudder the
experiment after it's revealed that the
machine at the center of things could
with a little light tweaking be turned
into a nuclear bomb after that nobody
sees or hears from Bruce Wayne for three
years but you'll know living you'll just
waiting hug him but things to go bad
again the tough on crime laws inspired
by the death of Harvey Dent called the
dent Act have allowed now Commissioner
Gordon to wipe crime off the streets of
Gotham but at a great cost to his
conscience he's drafted a letter of
resignation admitting to his and
Batman's ruse he keeps the letter closed
but stays on the force mentoring a young
officer
john blake meanwhile overseas the League
of Shadows has been reformed thanks to
two leaders Talia al Ghul and Bane after
years of work the to begin enacting a
plan to finish what their predecessors
started and destroy Gotham John Daggett
a crooked construction company owner
brings Bane to the United States in the
hopes of taking over Wayne Enterprises
his plan involves a stock market raid
and shady business dealings after first
employing Bane to help secure diamond
mining rights in Africa of course a
merry series of mishaps occur Daggett is
killed by Dane who's been using the
business man's construction firms to
plant explosives all over Gotham in
order to protect Wayne Enterprises from
a hostile takeover Bruce hands control
of his company to fellow clean energy
enthusiast Miranda Tate who he doesn't
yet realize is in league with the leak
Bruce brings the Batman persona out of
retirement and with the help of a live
jewel thief tracks Bane to Gotham sewers
however Selina Kyle the jewel thief was
working with Bane who's waiting for
Batman he lays a thick layer of the
smackdown on bats then has him
imprisoned in the pit where he's
tortured with a TV view of the
destruction of his beloved City with
Gotham's Dark Knight out of the way Bane
closes off all land entrances to the
city blowing up bridges and tunnels but
his liberators to control this city to
the people he then drops the truth on
the public Harvey Dent was a killer the
dent act was unjust and Bane has turned
Wayne Enterprises clean energy project
into a bomb which will explode when an
unknown got the might presses the button
the bomb will explode regardless of
whether or not it's triggered but Bane
uses the chaos to impose martial law
releasing the criminals in Blackgate
prison and employing Batman's stolen
armoury of vehicles for around six
months Gotham is a military state where
any crime is punishable by execution
Bruce meanwhile is still recovering from
his injuries he learns about the
prison's history and makes several
attempts to escape the pit finally
sticking the landing the third time
through unseen means and with no money
or resources he returns to the United
States and infiltrates Gotham's blockade
back in the city he loves Batman reaches
out to the jewel thief who betrayed him
before because he has a good feeling
about her sometimes in a story about a
guy who fights crime with animals
shaped boomerangs you just have to
suspend your disbelief boom with the
help of the city surviving police force
Batman and Catwoman go to war with Bane
and yet another twist it's revealed that
Bane was never in charge of the League
of Shadows
he was the Darth Vader to the Emperor
Palpatine that is Miranda Tate aka Talia
al Ghul
Talia takes off to protect the bomb
while Catwoman takes the opening and
explodes Bane with a shot from the
Batpod she has on loan together the
heroes chased down Talia and Bruce
forces her truck off the road killing
her and really making the audience look
back at all those car crashes he's
caused over the course of the trilogy
with the more skeptical eye towards his
no killing policy in a final act of
bravery Batman latches the bomb to his
snazzy helicopter making sure we all
know that the autopilot is on the fritz
and that this is the only way he flies
the explosive out over open water and
with a tug at our heartstrings blows
right up or does he a number of things
change in the months following the siege
of Gotham the public's trust in Batman
is restored enough so that a statue of
the Caped Crusader is commissioned Bruce
Wayne is pronounced dead and a token
funeral is held sparsely attended by
Alfred John Blake Lucius Fox and James
Gordon who after years of cooperation
finally pieces together that Batman and
the only guy in the city who could
afford a custom VTOL aircraft might be
one in the same person the Wayne fortune
is left to Alfred Wayne Manor is
converted into a home for orphans and
at-risk kids John Blake recently having
left the police force over concerns with
its effectiveness is left with
instructions on how to enter the Batcave
this is where we learn his first name is
Robin implying that he will soon possess
the least effective secret identity in
superhero history and then Lucius
discovers that the aircraft Bruce flew
into that long good night actually had
its autopilot functions repaired
sometime later Alfred goes to get lunch
at an Italian cafe that he'd told Bruce
about there he sees Bruce and selina
enjoying a meal is it a dream the
wishful imaginings of an old man or did
Batman really escape Gotham to start a
new life with Catwoman well since we
don't see any inception style top
spinning we're going to assume that the
Dark Knight trilogy concludes with a
happy ending check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]